what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you get decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
Bob cor let me tell you something
Aquaman luce something off captain carry
kappa Karen he's a super funny
I love captain careful captain karen is
one of my favorite characters ever and
just the history of convoys because he's
just fine like he's a fun goofy
character like this that's really all he
is he's just a fun silly character of
course this comes out of 1980s comic
books anybody who knows anything about
the history of comics will tell you
everybody in the 1980s was crazy and
captain caret was no different so here's
deal so this is this is the origin story
of Captain Karen but the difference with
this is that this was actually like a
preview this is as close as we get to
the origin this is a preview for Captain
Karen and the zoo crew and that's
usually what comes when she did back in
really back in that time period even now
they do it to a degree but not so much
they just kind of give you solicitation
at the end of comic books can just say
hey this is going to be considered on
and such and such and such and such and
types of such or hey be sure to check
out this this and this the only real
exception of that that you find is
Valiant Comics a diet comics will still
do previews for upcoming solar upcoming
stories especially when you went through
in like the early Valiant Comics with
like you know the relaunch and are you
know around 2000 as well you know when
you read like XO man award they were
doing previews for upcoming characters
it was a really good way to kind of reel
people in to grab the man there were
four pages or something like that they
weren't super lengthy but it was still
pretty cool to see so it's good to see
that kind of thing is still a part of
the colorful community but with regards
to this this basically just a preview to
give us the origin and what it does is
it picks up with Clark Kent right and
the only thing that we get here just
kind of picks up in the middle of
everything what we're basically told is
that you know Clark in of course being a
news anchor at this point in time and
the publication of DC Comics is
basically dealing with is reporting on
the idea that people are losing their
people are just kind of devolving down
into their most base form and that's the
common theme here is that for some
reason or another people are de-evolving
that initially it takes on a tick before
of their actions within like they're
they're very nuances their own personal
you know concepts begin to follow suit
and the 50s people hanging from trees
eating bananas you know so on and so
forth and well not everybody has been
affected by it it does raise concern of
course because the fact this is being
viewed as like a pandemic of sorts eels
going around the city of Metropolis
once Clark Kent's able to get away from
being on the news he of course
transforms in the Superman of the
question is how do we deal with this
we're in the middle of him kind of
investigating what it is is going on
another guy is too
we hit by this way of life that be
evolves him back into acting like an
eight now again that's kind of the
interesting thing about Superman is that
during this time in the 1980s DC was
writing anything they could to get
people to read Superman because you got
to remember throwing from your four
decades in decades Superman was like the
front face of DC and even now he is we
see man is the face of DC Comics he's a
character they guard jealously I mean
the Superman symbol is more recognizable
than the Christian cross but in terms of
readers and in terms of overall
popularity among color book fans I would
say Batman is probably more popular now
we know that because Batman comics
outsell Superman's comics so the proof
is in the pudding but with regards to
his character as he was being written
here this was around the time where
Superman was basically being having his
powers reduced that was a Julius
Schwartz idea he wanted to drop off keep
math powers make it more relatable
nullify the weakness of kryptonite and
fans hated it they wanted to see
spacefaring adventures and so because of
this Penn started turning to other
publications in DC and the numbers of
that man began to bolster they began to
grow expanded on by the IDS of the
post-crisis landscape and the idea of a
Batman becoming you know that mean
becoming doctor now that hadn't happened
at this point this story was written in
1982 some Titans number 16 but this was
where Superman was on his way out this
is where sube was on his way to losing
popularity and being replaced by Batman
that's telling book fans favorite DC
hero now having said that of course with
Superman going through and investigating
traces the source of this origin or the
source of this of this beam coming from
Pluto as best as he can tell now of
course this is where we kind of start to
get into this weird situation of
Superman having powers of convenient
scale in a sense that one of the things
that he says is what your way to change
into his Clark Kent outfit he had a
special pocket in his Superman suit
where he stores as Clark Kent uniform so
this is one of the weird little nuances
that we get here and there but the
problem is once you tries to basically
leave a planet earth there's an
invisible barrier that keeps him there
but he ends up realized there's a meteor
that actually crashes through the
barrier and so Superman kind of realizes
well if the meteor can come through the
barrier from the other side then I can
use the meteor to go through the barrier
from this side now of course that makes
no sense it's basically creating a coral
area where none exists you know it's
like saying well because it's 12 o'clock
now that means it's lunchtime
looks like say well because it's 12 a.m.
that means it's lunchtime 12 p.m. 12
a.m. or not the same thing and it
creates kind of a funny scenario here
but again it's just kinda
weird you know in terms of how this
unfolds but once he breaks through this
this weird dimensional barrier he
suddenly ends up fighting himself and
basically another another universe you
know another another earth now the funny
thing about this is initially right off
the bat he doesn't pick up on what's
going on and said he's just kind of like
oh hey there's a Daily Planet I'll just
go there and I'll change back into Clark
Kent and I'll try to see if I could
figure out what's going on he goes to
his desk and he sits down on a lap of a
guy by the name of Roger Rabbit now to
be honest with you guys as far as know
where Roger Rabbit is a Disney property
and so I'm not really sure how he
reconcile these two things of DC using
the name of Roger Rabbit and and busily
owning it I'm not a hundred so sure
about that but let the guards to
Superman transom in the barrier showing
up in this cartoon world this was just
written for the sake of convenience and
that's how a lot of comic books were
done back then I mean this day and age
things are done for the sake of
convenience to a degree the people are
also a little wiser now that they've
kind of picked up on what comic books
traditionally used to do and so if
suddenly somebody just appeared
somewhere and there was no explanation
for how they got there and Kalecgos fans
would be like what's going on here like
we need some kind of explanation here
like we need some kind of answer oh
that's usually kind of left a continuity
sticklers but in this day and age they
don't really do that much anymore
instead it takes like 15 story arcs to
get to that point you know for example
the death of Charles Xavier and Marvel
Comics during adventures versus
excellence that wasn't something to just
suddenly happen it wasn't like Cyclops
suddenly became a bad guy
Cyclops becoming a villain has its roots
all the way back in deadly Genesis after
the House of M so it was a 10-year
long-running event leading up to the
point where Cyclops became a bad guy it
was a gradual change in his character
over the years but again that's just
kind of a kind of what they do now in
the modern days as opposed to just back
then where things were done quick fast
and in a hurry and there something to be
said about doing comic books in this
fashion but the fact remains here that
of course you know with Clark Kent
sitting down on the lap of Roger Rabbit
Roger Rabbit freaking out he's just like
what in the hell is going on like it's a
talking rabbit and I love so much about
this because like look Superman I don't
mean to be the bearer of bad news man
but like you can fly because the Yellow
Sun allows you to fly is it really that
hard to believe
and such a thing is like a
rabbit not only that Roger Rabbit is
basically this allegory of Clark Kent in
the sense that he is an artist who's not
really a view a press guy he's on a
newspaper guy but Roger Rabbit
also created a superhero called Super
score which is the animal version of
Superman and that's what this planet is
this planet or I guess it's universe is
one where instead of humans being
sentient it's animals who are Cynthia it
Oh rabbits and ducks and moose looses
and so I was overkill they're all just
kind of each sentient things of course
with Superman kind of asking one of the
world's going on Roger Rabbit being it's
curious about Superman as Superman is
about him their conversation is pretty
simple here that's one of the other
things it kind of touches home so it's
grounded as you can get with a guy that
can just remember in alien it can fly
kind of situation so of course Roger I
was kind of talking to him grabs a
carrot eat something cured a little bit
so on and so forth you know any kind of
talks about how you know he has a
costume that he wore to a Halloween
party you know to dress up as a
superhero that kind of thing but what is
it taking place here is one of the
beings on this animal world it's hit by
the same being that hit Superman's earth
and those individuals began to begin to
devolve instead of it you know turning
and like a an a4 something like that
it's the city and dogged evolving down
into its baseline city and form a dog is
we would recognize him so for Superman
x-rays via the the pod that has these
carrots knocks to carrot out of Rogers
hands only for Roger to begin kind of
absorbing this energy and turning into
like a super-powered being now of course
you know in his anger he punches
Superman you know but uh he doesn't
realize how strong he is it's really you
know knocks him through a wall and
that's when we basically get captain
carrot that's when he basically donned
this little cosplay outfit that's
constantly made for himself calling
himself a superhero and he and Superman
basically team up to face off against
these guys against whatever this force
is now in terms of what this force is
basically sent all these animals into
their base states as to the people on
earth into their base states that
carries on into captain carrot and his
amazing zoo crew storyline we don't
really find out exactly what all had
happened at least not in this particular
story I said you know it just kind of
it's a way for before DC to basically
kind of engineer the two of them meeting
one another and then set captain carrot
off on his own story but again captain
carrot and his amazing zoo crew that's
been a story I've actually not been able
to get my hands on otherwise we would
have just done that but yes it's
impossible to get a hold of as far as
I'm aware but this is the origin story
of Catholic Eric have to care of a super
bunny I love captain Carrick
I love captain carrots characters but if
you guys are new here - how much explain
make sure you guys to the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah
people comment down below let me know
what you guys think if you guys really
really want to see it I'll try to get my
hands on captain Kerr and his amazing
zoo crew but no promises I mean it's
super difficult to get a hold of so if
you guys are interested in that leave a
comment down below and I will catch you
all later please
[Applause]
[Music]